[Musique]
depuis 12 ans je peux dire qu'on en a
traversé des crises faut avoir le pied
marin en restauration celle là on était
face à l'inconnu
retour ému et une reprise timide
lysandre vaugeois n'a pas revu sa
patronne et les cuisiniers depuis deux
mois très spécial de rentrer il savait
le changement c'est nul car même la
fermeture du restaurant s'est imposé de
manière subite le 15 mars dernier après
l'annulation de tous les spectacles au
théâtre voisin le 15
après le brunch on sait dire au revoir
pour un certain temps j'ai mis à pied 19
employés
donc c'est ça
vététistes mais très vite la
restauratrice s'est remise au boulot
avec son chef est la mise au point des
façons d'adapter ses risotto c'est
tartare et son boudin noir pour que les
clients les réchauffe à la maison c'est
beaucoup des crc ont fait des tests on
essaie des choses on se fie aux
commentaires contre les clients il s'est
développé le nouveau côté de la
restauration qu'on connaissait pas
encore dans la première semaine de mai
la petite équipe a réussi à vendre près
du tiers des plats qu'elle sert
normalement sur place ce qui a entraîné
le retour d'un deuxième cuisinier et
l'arrivée ce matin-là de lysandre la
serveuse pour prendre en charge les
commandes par téléphone et par internet
14% des restaurateurs indépendants du
canada n'ont pas pu payer leur loyer en
avril sept sur dix se demandent s'ils
vont y arriver en mai anik beaudoin s'en
sort mieux
elle a pu s'entendre avec le
propriétaire de son immeuble le pour
l'instant on parle pas de rentabilité on
parle vraiment d'arriver ce qu'on
appelle le break-even c'est vraiment de
maintenir
le pack bull qui sont alignés à la bonne
place
pas longtemps qu'ils aient fermé le loup
est long le très content qu'il ait ou
pas ses portes une fois par semaine mon
à léo lui manger ma poutine c'est que je
serai content que les autres gastronomie
mêmes défis chez louis célèbre
institution de la restauration rapide à
sherbrooke le patron à réaménager
l'espace de sa salle à manger pour
offrir des repas à emporter en toute
sécurité
je n'aurais jamais pensé de voir ça dans
ma vie locale comme tout le monde
d'ailleurs
après on fait ça m'intéresserait de nous
tienne c'est un sou pour eux dans son
voeu que revienne
le louis initiale a été lancé il y à 70
ans
pierre ellison gère maintenant 3 louis
la fermeture de ces restos en mars la
force et à licencier 130 employés
fava nos cages à mafate seule mine fabie
mises à pied avec sa nouvelle formule le
patron pense pouvoir tenir quelques mois
une quarantaine d'employés ont
recommencé à s'activer autour des
plaques de cuisson et des friteuses
envoi de noir ou bout du tunnel
la lumière est pas fort
[Musique]
quand je vais porter le sacre d'un
coffre de la voiture que je croise les
yeux d'une cliente de clients que je
connais le piquant on est content de ce
bourg se fait du bien
à paris
on ne va pas maintenant
pour répondre aux normes de
distanciation années que baudouin songe
maintenant à transformer sa salle à
manger et offrir à ses clients une
nouvelle expérience esthétique
conviendra le déconfinement un peu
anxiogène
parce que pour moi tout est basé sur ste
marie la cuisine ouverte
l'ambiance donc sage et par oui j'ai
peur que les clients soient pas
nécessairement au rendez vous même à
long terme
les restaurateurs ne savent toujours pas
quand ils seront autorisés à ouvrir leur
salle à manger et surtout dans quelles
conditions la menace sanitaire prolonger
va certainement les forcer à se
réinventer
[Musique]